by now a lot of you know my secret since
the photos have been leaking online yes
I am terribly short in real life now
throw your Stones if you must in the
comment section but your words will not
hurt me because I am a small Target now
of course the real secret is obviously
that I went on Joe Rogan did about a
three-hour podcast and I didn't want to
say anything when we were setting it up
a couple months ago because the whole
time I'm thinking there's been an error
you know this guy has to have famous
people to talk to or important people
maybe but sure enough
it happened and uh yeah I just wanted to
take a moment to highlight my three
favorite moments from The Experience
starting with the Logan Paul and crypto
Zoo
um part we gotta talk about so obviously
most people know that Logan Paul
promised to refund the victims but the
behind the scenes information which I
haven't talked about is that he hasn't
actually paid anyone yet he hasn't even
said a word to his community since
January when he got in trouble and it's
just been really frustrating to watch
because frankly I'm tired of talking
about Logan but many of these people are
helplessly waiting and begging for Logan
to respond to them and they've been
getting nothing so I followed up with
Logan privately twice about the lack of
refunds uh and heard nothing I got left
on red so I finally decided to make it
public enjoy you told everyone it was
going to make the money and then you
never delivered anything so my story was
basically
showing that showing the victims of the
scheme and in response he's like well
I'm going to sue you for that he said
he's going to see you yeah he said I'll
see you in court
and then the backlash against him was so
severe that he releases a video saying
thank you coffeezilla for showing at the
world what happened and I appreciate it
I responded out of anger but I'm gonna
make things right I'm gonna fix the game
to what it was supposed to be and I'm
gonna pay back
1.7 million dollars I'm committing 1.7
million to anyone who bought an nft can
get a refund now there's a bit of an
issue with that so that's nice I
actually think it's great that that
happened but uh there's two issues with
it number one which is that
the nfts were only half a small part of
the sale they actually weren't even half
they were because people bought these
tokens so the people who bought tokens
get nothing he's offering you know this
refund on the the nfts the other problem
is he hasn't refunded the nfts it's been
like over a month since he's done this
so he said he's going to do it and then
the Discord put like he's posting in
this little chat room with the investors
after he said he was going to do it he's
posted nothing there's no way to get a
refund right now so I keep asking him
like Hey where's you promised 1.7
million to these investors they're all
waiting like it's been over uh I think
it's almost been two months now and
there's nothing so it's like you know he
says that he's refunding people which
sounds great for PR and then it's just
like radio silence so my experience
because I've talked to Logan and that's
why I know he didn't respond to me
because I I texted him I said Hey
where's this money he left me on red but
I've talked to him and when I talk to
him there's just sort of this feeling of
he's like I just don't want to think
about this like I don't want to be you
know he wants to focus on Prime which is
successful he doesn't want to be
bothered with the victims of the scheme
that he ultimately thought of in the
first place is it possible that he's
just Gathering the money or working out
a way to do it legally where it it makes
sense it's it's very frustrating because
you know at at every turn it's just sort
of like uh you know it is I want to say
it's possible we just don't know and
it's just sort of like
when you promise people re refunds like
the longer you wait you know the less
people are actually going to take that
refund if Walmart says hey bring in
bring in this skull I'll give you a
refund and you're like all right when
can I bring it in and then I'll respond
to you for two months
they know that you're less likely to
actually take the refund so I don't know
if he's doing it because he wants less
people to get the refund he probably is
busy but my thought is
a transgression of this magnitude where
you're playing with people's money and
livelihoods you cannot take it lightly
and that's one of the things is these
influencers got into this crypto space I
don't think they fully appreciated
they're now dealing with financial
investments and it's not a joke it's not
like a brand deal where you know if uh
nordvpn isn't as great as they said it
was you know it's all cool right it's
now it's your company and you promise
people you're gonna make the money and
now you haven't said anything for over a
year then you say you're going to refund
them and you don't say anything for two
months that's a that's an issue so
that's my favorite segment from the show
I just think it's so important to hold
these people accountable and the second
moment I wanted to talk about was uh
talking about Ai and deep fake scams
which is something I'm concerned about
but I haven't gotten the chance to talk
about too much just recently one went
viral using Joe Rogan and I wanted to
get his response to it after I had done
some research here's a clip of the deep
fake scam and his reaction to it and the
AI stuff's scary because ultimately
you'll get the AI deep faking you into
you know yeah there's one of me it was
one of me and Andrew huberman selling
some supplement that's not real right
yeah Alpha I don't know if the
supplement's real but I know that the
commercial's certainly not real I mean
Andrew Look alphagrid's only been out
for two months but if you go to Amazon
and you search testosterone booster for
men Amazon already has it at the top of
the search ranking yeah they they deep
faked you and I think it went viral on
Twitter for a bit yeah what everybody
knew was a deep fake luckily and it
wasn't quite good enough yeah and then
you know we tried to figure out who's
doing it and you just run into a bunch
of shells it's like very difficult I'll
tell you offline who's doing it okay I
know I looked into it because I was
curious I was curious and uh you know
that same person I put out a lot of ads
about like Kim Kardashian had they had
deep fake of Kim okay so I'm gonna share
Pete's secret for his feedee they had
one of you saying that like so they have
one of you saying like this product's
great you know go buy it and then
there's another one where you were
complaining that Andrew Tate launched it
and you thought you were sort of like
Andrew Tate's going after my brand so
Andrew Tate made this competing product
to Alpha Brain he called it Alpha Brian
and it's a coffee with some nootropic
and test boosting ingredients in there
hey I'm not sure if that was a slight at
me for some of the past comments I had
made like masculinity yeah I will say
I'm impressed with the formula
I respect what he's doing and all around
I mean I guess just hats off
although I wish he wasn't competing with
me it was kind of this hilarious thing
where they were playing both sides it's
like it's Joe Rogan's it's also Joe
Rogan Tate like hates that it's out
there because it's so good then it's
like Kim Kardashian loves it they had
every celebrity was like basically
endorsing this thing all through Ai and
it's just the Testament of our times
like
celebrities are the new sort of
authorities
for better and often For Worse
um but like but people use that as
currency now and like with AI you can
just like fake a lot of that stuff
um that's what I'm worried about is the
volley I feel like this is the very
first volley in a war on reality this is
a weird experience showing the person
who was used in the fake ad like the
fake ad but something I actually forgot
to mention in the show which I think
makes it 10 times worse is that the
person who sells this Alpha grind
product or the and uses these AI scams
uh goes by the name of Genius CEO and he
sells a course on selling on Amazon so
it's not just Preposterous that he uses
it to sell the product itself he then
brags about it online where these
products are getting sold by AI scams
and then he sells a course I guess on
how to do the same thing let me tell you
a story of how I made 300K in two months
and yes there is some artificial
intelligence in this story very strange
I forgot to mention it and I just wanted
to correct that and I I also want to say
this technology is only gonna get more
creepy so yeah the future it's not great
now the final part of the show I wanted
to highlight is a Celsius rant which if
you haven't seen that video you can go
check it out right now but it's just
also a rant about scams in general and
it really sums up a lot of my thinking
lately uh just the problem of these
scams being under prosecuted criminally
and um yeah I I hope you enjoy I watched
the Celsius video that you put out
recently and I watched it today and I
was like this is so valuable because I'm
seeing all these people because you you
showed those people that did get scammed
and the people that get [__] over by
this guy who created this thing and you
know they have a voice now and you can
you you can also like let all these
other [__] that are trying to
do something like that know that coffee
zilla's out there and he's going to find
you and he's gonna put you on blast and
people are gonna know and it's gonna be
more difficult for the next person and
again it's not the wealthy investors
that will sue it's these people that put
in two thousand dollars and it's the
only two thousand dollars they had
that's that's where it's so valuable and
and I know that you feel that way and it
comes through in your video and I think
that's why it's appealing that's why
it's working
I I really discovered early on that
nobody cares about the numbers the
numbers are like the headline or
whatever but ultimately you can't make a
like this stuff doesn't matter until you
get people involved yeah until you hear
the victims talk they're the heartbeat
of everything because until you hear
that like what's a billion dollar it's
impossible to know yeah and it's not and
then and then you watch the guy and
you're like this who would fall for this
you know like it's easy to get cynical
if you just see the numbers and the guy
who defrauded people yeah the second you
humanize it and you show a person and
all of a sudden you see someone with all
the same problems and you can just tell
you can see it in their eyes and they're
just wrecked by this guy who who they
believe who truly they believed it it's
like the biggest betrayal you trusted
somebody with everything and then they
stab you in the back like this uh Alex
machinski CEO of Celsius his whole thing
was banks are evil which is not
crazy I mean it's like you know you can
understand why a lot of people resonated
with that they're like and it wasn't
even evil yeah yeah sorry I was going to
correct that he said like they're greedy
yeah and that's true like it's like and
he's not yeah yeah he goes like banks
are not your friends true statement Alex
and then this interviewers like but Alex
is your friend and he's like yeah he's
like you basically you can take the same
ride as me eight percent eight percent a
year I'll just give it to you you know
we're we're giving we're doing the same
thing as the banks we're loaning out
your money but we're gonna pass on 80 of
the revenue back to you instead of the
banks which they take all your money
right
um so people bought into that they said
that sounds great like a new hey the
internet changed everything you know we
think crypto is going to change
everything why not have a bank that
instead instead of serving as
shareholders it serves its customers it
kind of like there's something that
makes sense there it's really compelling
and then come to find out Celsius was
never making money they said they were
paying out you know you with uh with
their profits they were paying out you
with new deposits like new people were
coming in and they were paying you out
and so it was this giant Ponzi scheme
where they set the rewards because they
knew if it's high enough people are just
going to flock to them and so but they
had this compelling explanation for why
like it kind of made it kind of made a
little bit of sense and then they when
it finally goes wrong
he just get he just walks away I mean
yeah he's getting sued civilly but
where's the criminal action he's going
to go to jail probably not
and it's like that is so messed up that
is such a that itself is a crime I I
think it's so sick that we allow we
throw the book at people who will rob a
store with a gun right still ten
thousand bucks
people who still millions billions of
dollars often get away with it
because it's just done a little
differently there's not the drama of the
gun and somebody's and even if no one
just gets shot there's it's just hey
it's just he pushed a few pencils around
he got you to sign a few shitty but
that's just as sick and twisted but it's
just done in a way that socially is
slightly more acceptable and get they
get away with it way more often but I
would contend that these people are
literally financially murdering people
after Celsius people committed
because of lit I mean literally it's a
fact people come inside because they
lost everything I'm sure FTX as well of
course you know the bigger the bigger
the scam there's just statistically it
almost becomes impossible that you don't
at least
if not financially sort of
metaphorically murdering a family you
literally kill somebody and people walk
away with
not like either only the guy at the top
goes down or nobody goes down and that
is crazy to me it's like what message
are we sending
via our our Regulators basically it's
like hey you're gonna get a slap on the
wrist
if you're caught and this what you just
did is why you're so successful that's
real this is how you really feel this is
your re and this is why your show works
and this is this is it right there like
what you just did is why I'm interested
in your show because it's this is your
real thought something has to change I
mean something has to change where you
can't you can't just go go on like this
where if if we're really going to allow
if if we're going to you know take our
financial future in our own hands we're
going to allow these influencers to talk
about Finance somebody has to be there
when things go wrong yes and there has
to be consequences if you lie and if you
cheat and you steal there has to be a
guy at the end of the day who's gonna
put you in trouble and I think a YouTube
video is not nearly enough that's why
I'm constantly saying like hey
okay it's up from someone from the
government get involved like go [__]
this guy up go lock somebody you know
I know it's like a lot of this is new
like the crypto stuff is new but it
they're doing old crimes in a new way
yeah it's always been illegal to steal
people's money and that is what's
happening and that's why I put these
people on my show so you don't think
it's some like rug pool where it's all
fake money no there was real money in
these companies
and they just stole it a new way but
it's they're still stealing money and
the fact that we haven't found a way to
put some of these people in jail is
mind-blowing to me and we're sending a
bad message that hey just keep doing it
just go start a new there are people now
uh they were trying to start GTX after
FTX some new some new guys will try to
start like the new thing and it's like
TX is next
it's just like you know you have to
that's half the purpose of the law is to
it's partly you know for you know you
did something wrong you get punished but
also part of it is you do something
wrong you send a message to socially you
socially signal that we do not tolerate
this and right now the social signal
were were sending and accepting is if
you scam there's a very high likelihood
you will get away with it and if you
don't get away with it you'll get a
little slap on the wrist you'll get a
little fine
and that's not that's not working no
it's not well that's it in all
seriousness it was a surreal moment a
very cool one uh and I just appreciate
you all getting me this far thank you
for watching and even more than that
thank you for caring about these scams
ultimately I think we're shining a light
on a really important issue and um I'm
just grateful that anyone pays attention
so yeah thank you and I'll see you in
the next one